la une de paris match regardez
alors on va voir voilà eric zemmour et
sa très proche conseillère enquête sur
la jeune énarque qui dirige sa compagne
et c'est vrai que ça alors là ça a été
aujourd'hui mine de rien une un séisme
un séisme alors bernard montiel raconter
à nos téléspectateurs c'est là une de
paris match alors qui est cette jeune
fille s'appelle s'appelle sarah la faute
sa lé tout jeune c'est son attaché
parlementaire va travailler avec lui sa
conseillère elle est avec lui un peu
partout mais alors là où ils se
défendent un peu déjà passé
le week-end dernier où il était
justement il est en meeting enfin et mes
envies des déchets juste de eric zemmour
est ce qu'ils nient ce point je suis pas
du tout je connais pas ça salit privé
marié d'accord y est c'est bien et en
l'occurrence c'est pas c'est pas son
épouse d'accord maintenant paris match a
fait très attention ils n'ont pas dit
que c'était ça mais
c'est exactement il a raison ça ce sera
pour vendredi apparemment ce sera dans
d'autres journaux apparemment sébastien
qu'est ce qui se prépare oui je enfin
c'est quasi sûr que vendredi sorte une
autre série ou unis vont être moins
prudents que paris match et ils vont
dire clairement les choses alors c'est
une histoire une histoire conseils de
tous à peu près depuis plusieurs mois
d'action évident que ça allait sortir
d'autres façons il se cache absolument
pas d'accord donc voila moi j'ai eu les
photographes qui ont fait les ces photos
aujourd'hui ils m'ont dit que la veille
il était à toulon il s'est promené sur
le port avec quelle manière pas du tout
en milieu et que des gens prenaient des
photos avec eux avec leur téléphone et
qui s'est donc on a tous les droits non
non c'est à dire qu'avoir un seul mort
donc on a le droit de sortir des photos
mais appartement où ils se rejoignent
sur le port avec cette jeune femme et
qui laisse les gens de la rue le fait le
gratuit avec leur téléphone pourquoi un
jour des balades sur l'eau minérale ou
non à toutes les saloperies sont
autorisés dont celle là qu'il n'y a pas
de sa lola je vous écoute avec beaucoup
de patience avec votre petit air
goguenard mais il souriant de remuer la
merde puisque c'est votre métier
d'accord je vais vous dire que c'est
injuste
vous êtes sérieux avec votre femme
je vous dis c'est un sale métier accor
mais finir non mais me direz pas
terminée vous pouvez dire c'est comme ça
on peut pas bloquer et la vie est faite
comme ça on aimerait que l'adie soit
faite autrement on aimerait que vous
n'existiez pas aviver en dictature et
vous aurez pas de nom c'est par
l'informel après celle et la dictature
c'est qu'en excellents d'informations
quels éléments d'information alors tous
les gens qui l'ont vu se promener sur le
port de toulon est alors qu'ils ont fait
défaut d alors c'est la même chose que
ça et le journaliste me voyez moi de le
montrer vous êtes un journaliste le
maire d'essayer
je vais vous dire ce qu'ils pensent
cette une ça provoque chez moi un dégoût
chimiquement pur c'est votre ami tous
les moyens d'abord c'est mon ami mais
tous les moyens sont bons maintenant
pour abattre un homme alors je mens il a
réagi et jeté en pâture une femme à
l'opinion publique c'est pas pour
l'abattre et manuel valls le lac à peine
et est venue elle va je disais il ya des
proches zemmour à une famille zemmour a
des enfants évidemment vous vous vous en
foutez derrière ça il ya une manoeuvre
politique on va y venir j'espère donc
que moi j'espère simplement que ça va
coûter très cher à paris match non que
ça va coûter très cher je suis encore
chaud et je n'utilise pas torchant dans
le sens de torchon de cuisine mais dans
le sens de torcher le cul parce que
c'est le seul usage de cette une et
quand vous venez avec votre petit
sourire en coin mais c'est pas lui qui
l'a fait mais non mais justifié ce que
vous avez fait par le passé et justifier
cette une justifier ses moeurs de
vautours moi je vous dis vous me saoule
wenger c'est une sourire le coeur vous
me soulever le coeur
nourrir à vous nourrir et à céder de la
merde en pâture mais ce sera sombre
alors juste ne savez pas sur vous est-ce
que vous pensez que cette lune peut
détruire les ambitions présidentielles
d'eric zemmour manuel valls non je ne
crois pas au contraire mais d'abord je
pense qu'il faut des paris match est un
grand magazine mais c'était et mais la
manière dont ils le traitent ce n'est
pas la première fois ces tresses et
c'est très ennuyeux ou c'est pas en bus
ce qui sera fait on vient de l'apprendre
vendredi sera plus grossier mais ça
revient au même parce qu'au fond le
reportage ne porte pas sur eric zemmour
elle porte sur cette conseillère donc
voilà le jeu est donc là là faut faire
attention parce que moi je pense que la
protection de la vie privée le droit à
l'image sont quand même des éléments gg
moi j'ai fait d une de paris match
volontaire j'avais déjà très classique
quand j'étais premier ministre il ya une
une avec soussana avec china post cm qui
avec sous sa nouvelle celle qui est ma
femme qui est mon amoureuse mais suri et
c'était une photo volée vous attaquer
c'est raide et le politique ou même eric
zemmour se prépare à ça il sait que
c'est varié mais les proches c'est ça
c'est l'épreuve les proches ne fume
jamais préparé à ça c'est donc c'est
dégueu l'alors égrène les justement
alors qu'est ce que est ce que eric
zemmour est ce que ça peut lui porter
préjudice à renforcer annoncé
je pense que ça ne lui portera pas
préjudice du tout et il faut quand même
remettre les choses en place c'est que
quand on convoque la presse
pour une ora considérant sa grâce et sa
alors ben justement alors raconté
comment sa photo est né il a été deux
jours il ya eu deux événements et il a
été à ces deux événements avec cette
jeune femme en conviant la presse
kessler conseiller et sa conseillère et
quand on convient la presse et qu'on
annule une déambulation dix minutes
avant que tous les journalistes sont là
qu'on traverse la route pour aller se
baigner sur la plage vous pensez quoi
que les journalistes vont rien faire il
le voit partir d'un gars qui ils vont
rien faire donc je devrais pas ouvert au
départ au départ sébastien c'est un
reportage sur les déplacements d'eric
zemmour et ça s'est transformé en or
mais c'est à dire qu'il y avait il ya
samedi avait pas que paris match il y
avait toute la presse d'accord donc
voilà donc et tout le monde a vu qu'en
fait ils oui tout le monde a vu oui oui
d'accord mais on a vu donc il faudrait
que tous les journalistes voyait le
disons rien quelle est l'information une
photo numérique expliquez-moi
l'information vers hélary match bon
admettons qu'un journal respecte ses
terres on a le droit d'avoir des
informations sur la vie des hommes
politiques et ceux qui qui veulent nous
diriger gens pas
très brillantes et qui a fait sciences
po et qui conseille eric zemmour de loin
et qui veut absolument que eric zemmour
se présente donc c'est quelqu'un qui est
important dans la vie politique garder
le but a immigré à leur but et le timing
eric zemmour fait un sondage il est
donné à 11 % son égalisation laisserai
bien ça commence à inquiéter tout le
monde non mais c'est avant le soda non
mais non mais ça sort là pourquoi ce
soir là pourquoi précisément pour
essayer de casser une dynamique de
campagne on l'a vu par le passé mais
françois fillon et tant d'autres et donc
en réalité notre politique française est
gangréné par des méthodes de voyou jean
mesqui pas que photo paris match a fait
ça mais a choisi écoutez il va falloir
regarder comme un autre qui possède
paris match qui nous dirigent les
proximités jeu guerrier au monde
gattegno tranquillement vers le cloud et
dont on connaît les spectateurs monsieur
gattegno le directeur de la rédaction de
paris match et du journal du dimanche et
monsieur gattegno qui est notoirement
hostile à eric zemmour et pour dire les
choses gentiment pas très hostile à
monsieur macro et au pouvoir n'y voit
pas
voulu rien sur la table qui vont sortir
dans leur domaine bah oui ceux qui vont
sortir vendredi c'est au moment de ces
d'autres journaux qui sont pas dans le
même lot de moulins je vous parle je
crie au complot moi c'est juste j'aimais
bien la vérité c'est qu'eric zemmour ça
cartonne avec son débat là on a un scoop
de fou
eric naulleau je suis même persuadé que
encore une fois il convie toute la
presse il est pas idiot il connaissait
par coeur il sait très bien qui va être
coton je pense même qu au contraire
aujourd'hui est très heureux de faire la
une de paris match avec son but chic ce
soit personnel ou professionnel son but
à lui systématiquement c'est de choquer
nan c'est de faire le buzz et surtout de
crier systématiquement à la théorie du
complot ce qu'on est en train de faire
aujourd'hui des échanges et marées
noires et parler avec lui je peux vous
dire qu'il est parfaitement pour rien
s'il vous plaît le truc le plus
intéressant ce que tu viens de dire est
que vous avez eu eric zemmour je vous
dis que non il n'est pas heureux de cet
événement heureux de cette une est
certainement pas que quelqu'un qui a
l'air de lui et de proches soient jetés
en pâture à l'opinion publique et que
son nom viennent d'alsace la farine
c'est sa femme dans un contexte hors
politique quelle est l'information
politique de cette unité
en maîtrisant le dans le papier journal
très important ça va rien reportage sur
cette conseillère tout s'est tu alors
personne et ce sous couvert jeu parmi
ceux là qui la wii à la manif c'est là
c'est là où je pense qu'il ya vraiment
de débat il ya qu'est ce qu'on pense de
cette cour où on l'a dit chacun à signer
ce que vont voir les ensuite il ya les
conséquences alors les conséquences moi
je joue le jeu et sans cynisme en plus
je ne nie pas du tout que c'est lui qui
l'a provoqué mais je pense que dans le
monde politique telle qu'on lève alors
s'il y avait eu l'idée de l'abattre à
travers ce type d'information alors ce
qui n'est pas éventuellement aurait
envisagé cela je sais pas disent est
vrai mais se trompe totalement pensé que
ça varie au
contraire d'abord certains vont crier à
la pompe l'eau à la maison se victimiser
ou la victimisation nom que lui mais je
crois sincère n'y a pas de raison que je
doute de ce que vient de dire et hino
l'eau mais il ya ya ya mais là rien pour
le moment pour le moment où l'on verra
dans quelques mois mais pour le moment
il n'y a rien qui qui peut alors
l'atteindre après pour lui ce plan
personnel ça cet automne à avi bitton
est-ce que déjà c'est légal de publier
une photo comme ça l'unesco est ce qui
reste quelque chose paris match je vais
répondre aux aspects juridiques avant
tout la dimension politique n'est pas
lui faire du mal ça ressemble quand même
à une manoeuvre de basse police les
premiers réflexes en tant qu'avocat
c'est de me demander à qui profite le
crime qui a intérêt à ce que zemmour
s'effondrent et ne passe et fasse un
mauvais score au premier tour la
première qui a intérêt évidemment c'est
marine le pen - quelle choix au deuxième
tour ensuite que celles qui m'avaient
intérêts
qui a intérêt à avoir comme adversaire
au deuxième tour marine le pen bien
évidemment emmanuel macron si on
reproduit le schéma de la précédente
élection au deuxième tour emmanuel
macron marine le pen emmanuel mac on a
de grandes chances de gagner donc moi
aussi je dirais j'ai posé ça ensuite il
faut se demander effectivement qui est
le plus proche de paris match qui a les
liens les plus étroits avec paris match
est-ce que c'est marine le pen ou est-ce
que c'est emmanuel macron
c'est pour moi aussi je pense que les
éventuels lisez les éditos de la
teignouse demeurer gattegno rédacteur en
chef est tout à fait respectable mais
c'est plutôt anti m'apprend qu'autre
chose alors quand il ya des ja des
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent qui
régissent énormément sur cette affaire
et ils vous répondent eric naulleau
quand vous dites quelle est
l'information publique et pour les
informations politiques ils disent que
la formation politique sur twitter c'est
qu'il trompe sa femme donc il peut aussi
trompé les français s'ils étaient
appelés convoque la presse mais il fait
voir qu'ils trouvent ça rame sans gêne
et bat c'est tout tu trompes ta femme tu
te rappelles toi tu ne veux pas répondre
à ça alors mais bon c'est pas tant après
on sait pas quelles sont ses relations
avec son
livre dans son nouveau livre eric
zemmour raconte que du temps où il était
pleinement journalistes politiques tous
les journalistes politiques connaissait
la vie privée des politiques celles ne
revenaient même pas à l'idée d'en parler
c'était même pas interdit on
s'interdisait soi même d'en parler donc
on a basculé dans quelque chose donc
tout le monde sera victime un joueur
local a eu la sphère griveaux j'ai
trouvé totalement sordide j'étais
scandalisé parce qu'on lui a infligé
maintenant c'est zemmour demain ce sera
quelqu'un d'autre autour de ce plateau
ça tombera sur chacun d'entre nous et on
est entré dans une ère nouvelle si on ne
se révolte pas moi j'étais dans un jeu
je regrette mais la vie privée de
zemmour ou de quelqu'un d'autre qui ne
l'informant pas sur ce la manière qu'il
aurait aimé savoir faire et leur bazar
mais il y en a qui on a dit ça mais je
les vois ça sur les réseaux justement
nous à l'association des amis d'eric
zemmour ce qu'on constate depuis que ça
ses sorties c'est plutôt du soutien jeu
d'accord que ce n'était pas le but mais
c'est un soutien massif elysées et
françaises et les françaises se disent
match aller déjà les violer et c'est
justement parce que eric zemmour montre
donc les françaises et les français sont
pas dupes et nous on va continuer à
soutenir eric zemmour de manière très
large parce que s'il subit ça
aujourd'hui c'est précisément parce
qu'il commence à faire peur et donc nous
notre analyse c'est bon c'est pas cool
pour eric mais ça démontre qu'il
commence à prendre dans l'opinion et que
certains veulent lui barrer la route il
a réagi eric zemmour il faut croire que
je commence à inquiéter suffisamment
pour que paris match le caniche du
pouvoir essaye de me nuire je ne me
laisserai pas intimider et serait lassé
m'a dit ils se régalent voilà alors oui
alors comment je me sens quand ils sont
bons qu'à la tendance est d'abord eric
naulleau est hypocrite parce que eric
zemmour à chaque fois ils disaient oui
on a caché la fille de françois
mitterrand pendant des années quelle
honte bah si bien sûr que si il a
toujours condamné sa voix du tout et oui
pour le respect du temps mais j'ai
montré
le contraire il est revenu sur la ligne
opposée au
modèle et je pense qu'à lui il veut
justement ce pipoliser et je m'en
servirai qui ne va pas
petit temps il est entouré par une jeune
énarque absolument brillant comme il est
pareil ce brillant mais qu'elles ont dû
apprécier crise à l'horizon pas manger
du tout content du tout au tout ensuite
deuxième révolue salut virilise salé
roussillon et c'est le très bien pour
zemmour sinon
mais c'est tout comme
parti à lyon mais quand on fait un
meeting et qu on convie toute la presse
on va pas juste en face se baigner en
tançant qui aura pas de photos
de la presse la presse viennent
naturellement à la corde
c'est très bien
donc s'il voulait se cacher c'est pense
bête mais je suis fier de voir le jeu
mais la saloperie owei amoureux
alors bon je reconnais bien là dedans
plus nettement et que ce n'est pas le
mec là oui absolument pas attention il
est en pleine campagne il a tout un tout
un staff c'est fait c'est impossible
qu'il fasse pas ça en pleine conscience
il va sur la place d'en face ce billet
qu'une femme charmante et april
paparazzade a autant moi j'étais baratte
et parfois en vain de chercher
n'entendant montant des recoins là il
offre tout à la presse elle veut pas se
plaindre et pour moi y'a rien de
dégueulasse là dedans d'accord mais tu
es maintenant j'aimerais j'aimerais
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut lui
faire du mal est-ce que penser qu'il ya
des français qui vont se dire écoutez
moi après avoir vu ça je ne vais pas
porte-monnaie pour ça je pense que moi
je trouve pas que ça peut le faire du
mal seulement deux choses ce qu'il est
ce qu'ils ont dit à leur prendre une
photo quand bernard il prend une photo
pour mettre dans son téléphone pour
envoyer à jean-jacques c'est différent
là c'est paris match qui publie à grand
tirage moi moi le truc pour moi c'est
totalement volontaire ce qui fait rire
c'est simple quand il se met dans l'eau
comme ça avec une anarchie selon vous me
dites alors vous me dites qu'il est plus
marié mais la victime la victime s'est
pas eric zemmour lui fait nuit va dans
l'eau c'est nous qui dit non mais une
fille c'est pas sa femme alors été de
dire ouais c'est pas de sa faute s'il
veut si c'est pas sa femme ilva dans un
hôtel il va dans une piscine il va se
cacher là vous faites mais je compends
mais là aussi les marier ces messieurs
des factures alors
le geste et dire en même pas tu dors
pas bien et dire en même sentiment à
venir est pas idiot il a tout fait il
n'arrivait pas qu'ils en tirent profit
qu'ils le veulent organiser parce que je
sais faux ami lewis en ont
voulu à conscient consciemment c'est
faux il à
la victime c'est sa femme et sa famille
c'est pas lui c'est déjà de la victime
ce safari
manuel valls la victime s'est passé au
delà de ce qui a été dit de ce que j'ai
pu dire non la victime ce sera le débat
politique la wind rassis parce que si la
campagne présidentielle est lancée sans
aucune naïveté un qui est un vrai débat
y aura beaucoup de débats et des débats
sur le fond sur le passé le présent et
l'avenir de la france sur les grands
sujets mais si le débat c'est le risque
on le sait bien parce que faut pas être
hypocrite commence là dessus ça peut
concerner eric zemmour et sans jeu de
mots personnes on va vers quelque chose
qui très dangereux parce que parce que
c'est tout le système qui va dire les
français à la fois peuvent réagir à ça
mais au fond d'eux mêmes c'est pas c'est
pas ça qui veulent qu'ils veulent c'est
de savoir ce qu éventuellement eric
zemmour pan sur l'écologie sur
l'économie cela c'était du social sur
les retraites donc tout ça peut aller à
vau l'eau nous on n'est qu'au mois de
décembre
très macron avait été aussi victime de
beaucoup d'attaqués beaucoup
d'insinuations pendant la campagne nous
faut faut être fois n'y a pas eu de
faute au verbe comme ça non le nom lui
avait plutôt eu beaucoup phone est très
positive dans paris match mais mais mais
mais il faut dire faut faire attention
parce que le sist parce que le parce que
là le système se met sa part je connais
un peu moins jeudi il extrêmement
sérieux le rédacteur en chef de paris
match je ne vois pas égouttez de telle
ou telle personne est donc désole erik
90 je vois pas moi je vais vous dire la
vérité je suis paris match jean pas se
mentir bah oui un coup énorme ça va être
juste ça ça va être la une la plus
vendue delà de la saison
ya pas d euros l'autre
ils vont être condamnés oui mais bon ils
vont gagner beaucoup d'amis mais alors
alors justement vous allez la colline
avant ça fait beaucoup de si sébastien
évidemment pour moi c'est ça ils ont
juste la bonne photo il l'a bien sûr ça
ils savent qu'ils font un gros coup et
ça oui il sait tous n'y a pas de compte
où ils ont pas envoyé des gens pour le
chercher c'est vraiment extra convient
pas c'est pas emmanuel macron qui
m'appelait paris match et non là c'est
juste zemmour en ce moment il qu'on va
pas se mentir il cartonne partout où il
passe ils sont dix et il l'a fait il a
vendu 78 mille exemplaires de son livre
c'est record égalé de valérie
trierweiler et puis 2014 2014 exactement
ça bloque et this poids il dit ban ou
demain à la presse mine de rien
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué mon la
presse ils disent là eric zemmour avec
sa peau est sa très proche conseillère
générale acheter une charge virale en
menant 20 minutes en jambes et normes
donc donc venue elle a raison ça va être
super crasse pouilly la campagne alors
prenez pas on n'est pas au café des
sports mais je te livre classique au
service tv elle n'a pas élevé les
khallouf
ensuite le menu demain je voudrais avoir
notre avocat avi bitton qu'est ce que
risque paris match là parce qu'on m'a
parlé de l'adultère sur papier glacé
c'est quoi cette affaire alors je vais
vous dire ce que j'irai à azemmour s'il
venait me consulter je lui dirai
attention le procès va durer un certain
temps en référé quel peut-être un mois
ou deux une action au fond un an ou deux
et qu'est ce que vous allez obtenir au
bout en france malheureusement
le système est ce qu'il est les dommages
et intérêts ça sera pour une affaire
comme ça s'il gagne il a des chances de
gagner sur le plan juridique 1 je vais
pas vous livrer mon analyse mais il a
des chances de gagner choix de temps
juridique on peut considérer que c'est
une atteinte à la vie privée une
atteinte au droit à l'image a même si
c'est dans un lieu public et ses
cinq à dix mille euros 5,5
6,6 il a raison
serait on serait en danger les lignes et
les chiffres d'avant oui tout en
angleterre un homme politique avait
attaqué l'asean pour atteinte à sa vie
privée le sun avait été condamnée à
trois millions de livres sterling si
vous voulez là effectivement les
journalistes réfléchissent à marcher
dans l'équipe la diffamation pour moi si
vous voulez voilà le système est ce
qu'il est et si jamais eric zemmour
attaque en justice si tu vas faire il va
entretenir le feu médiatique sur cette
affaire dont on pensait qu'ils avaient
la campagne à des journalistes vont se
presser l'annoncé on va passer de quoi
le conseil de l'avocat enfin vraiment
moi en tant qu'avocat si j'avais un
conseil à lui donner je lui dirai laisse
béton ce
qui s'appelle biton
le coupable mais si vous les attendez on
peut avoir raison
raison sur le plan légal mais ça peut
être quand même une très mauvaise santé
la moyenne de russie était dit donc en
fait le coupable c'est le danois est en
fait à paris match je risque énorme et
sa magnifique
réformer la genre à vous adresser voit
un premier ministre pour faire en sorte
que la loi change et que les dommages et
intérêts soit à la mesure alors malkin à
la plus répressive du monde à ce sujet
il n'y a qu'en france où le droit à
l'image existe on a trouvé on a retrouvé
des photos d'eric zemmour avec sarah cma
fauquette c'est normal c'est sa
conseillère c'est normal qu'elle soit
continuer à ratisser comme vous vous
êtes ami d'eric zemmour cependant que
vous avez côté lui c'est normal et il
était présent un hommage et a été
présentée comme sa conseillère en
communication rené et c'est vrai que
c'est voilà ça c'est ya déjà des photos
ou deux qui sont sortis c'est vrai que
là cette photo c'est voilà paris match
sont ni dans l'eau un big voilà donc ça
fait combien d'années qui travaille avec
elle je sais pas du tout ce à plusieurs
mois plusieurs mois - d'accord très bien
elle a écouté en tout cas s'est mis en
retrait de la même surprise c'est que
ces hommes là sont extrêmement entoure
et surtout mari oui on parle que de lui
des conseillers en communication les
sanaryens 10 avions ici bas si avec tout
à commettre cette erreur cette traversée
de traverser la sibérie en face qui est
sûr c'est qu'elle a les jeunes osons la
personnaliser arrêtez moi je vais
aquaboulevard
c'est à dire que c'est une allure en
clairement service à eric zemmour depuis
quelques jours les médias d'une manière
générale le crédibilise en tant que
candidat notamment le faisant débat face
à jean luc mélenchon la part bond sur
cette une c'est pas un candidat que je
vois quelle politique on a l'habitude de
voir en une de paris match en vacances
torse nu cd président de la république
donc là on lui donne encore une autre
stature et ça le rend humain ça le rend
sympathique on le voit dans un autre
câble sûr je pense qu'il a tout à y
gagner eric zemmour résidant au delà des
dommages que ça sur sa vie privée alors
discutent un honnêtement ça
veut dire que tout le petit landernau
médiatique français parisien les
journalistes peuvent savoir qu'il ya
cette relation de cette collaboratrice
et le peuple français les gens les
électeurs n'ont pas droit de le savoir
du privé commence vraiment eu écho
mondial
je ne pense pas que la vie privée
informe sur la qualité d'un homme
politique et moi je suis nostalgique du
temps ses collaboratrices est justement
et non je suis nostalgique du temps
évoqué moore dans son livre ou où se
retenait d'évoquer la vie privée des
hommes politiques je trouve ça beaucoup
plus digne je trouve qu'on est entré
dans une période habilité pour l'instant
vous vous en réjouissez parce que ça
leur parle de
lui
on a tous les droits sans registre du
tout c'est franchement
on sort il joue pas du tout eric un non
mais moi j'ai entendu c'est bien fait
pour lui et c'est lui le coupable si je
fais la moyenne les styles en courant
avec eric zemmour qui a d'autres photos
qui vont sortir dans d'autres journaux
indiquent vendredi non je n'ai pas parlé
avec lui après ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'il est très remonté donc si le but
c'était vraiment de lui miner le moral
et lui casser les jambes c'est raté
les plus en forme que jamais aussi
d'étendre cette petite musique sa la
range donc il est il a un peu fait
exprès je trouve ça inadmissible
inadmissible d'entendre ça autant vous
le dire mais c'est bien cool disait
que ça et à l'assassinât pas qui est ce
que ça rame et j'ai entendu beaucoup
avec des nuances nous entendu beaucoup
ça mais tout ça c'était important que
vous ayez aussi également eric naulleau
est en tout cas ça va pas casser les
jambes des soutiens non plus
nous on y voit vraiment génial que ben
il peut gagner si on leur taxation la
mieux l'attaquer sur ce qu'il dit sur le
fond c'est ce que vous pensez voilà y'a
de quoi faire ouais bah y'a quoi faire
bien sûr mais c'est sur le fond justin
la jeune femme lundi annoncé qu'elle se
mettait en retrait de la cour des
comptes où elle est magistrate alors est
ce qu elle l avait déjà eu vent que son
saut qu'elle serait jetée en pâture
comme ça ou pas en tout cas dès lundi
elle s'est mis en retrait de la cour des
comptes joli hâle est jeune elle est
jolie
[Musique]
j'ai la réponse n'a aucun rapport
d'accord eric eric naulleau exprimer
eric zemmour sébastien tout à l'heure a
laissé entendre qu'il est sortir des
choses pires le week end non mais on l'a
dit vendredi non je ne pense pas qu'il
va le savoir bientôt plus parlante
piscine à gaza c est le texte va être
plus clair que dans paris match lui
disait rien